[Music]
several years ago we were in vegas vegas
baby vegas baby and we were at uh a
douchey club douchey baby this club that
kept playing that song
uh shot what how does it go shots shot
shot shot
how does shots go and then it cuts off
and then they say it's patron time oh
yeah so every time they would play that
the proprietors of this establishment
would come over with uh shots for us a
tequila huge shots we were there with
our friend kier they kept hanging out
and we were like oh no no thank you no
we're fine it's like every 15 minutes
they brought over shots
at a certain point we'd cheers and then
we would dump them out it was a quick
move it was like a sleight of hand where
you go oh because they all wanted a
drink with us and cheers cheers so cut
to
an hour and a half two hours later we're
walking out of said club and our friend
kier barely walking and he said i can't
believe we just did that that was you
know something of that effect and justin
said i know thank god we were dumping
those out can you imagine if we hadn't
we would be like in the hospital
and he goes he's like what training and
he was like what do you mean
like the shots we were dumping them out
you weren't dumping them out they were
like and he's like i didn't know you
were dumping them out like there were
like 11 or 12 rounds of them at least at
least then i got immediately impressed
because keir was like he wasn't like
sloppier that's that's happy ending here
survived life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life you're short
i'm your host justin long life could be
a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is
my uh tequila
i was gonna say tequila hating but you
don't hate to eat no i'm okay with
tequila yeah i know people some people
have really bad experiences with tequila
is one of those things where if you have
to kill ya too much one night then the
rest of your life you you know have a
problem with it i i've never had one of
those nights it happened to me recently
where i just had too much but who cares
i got hung over but uh our frank here
was he's also very stocky he's uh sturdy
he's stalking no no he's i mean stocky i
meant he's from a sturdy stock that's
what i meant dirty he's sturdy he's a
sturdy stock he's not stocking not stuck
anyway so here our friend who uh we're
hoping isn't offended that we shared the
story he's the best
he's the best so he was in a
little movie called wedding crashers he
played todd in wedding crashers
and our guest today
was also
in wedding crashers yes our guest today
is
well i say it all the time it's not
gonna stop uh he's my favorite another
star of that movie
our guest today is vince vaughn we
landed a whale we sure did this little
fisherman finally put out some chum that
was able to you know attract the the big
one um yeah we got vince to do vince had
been talking about we've been talking
about doing it for a while and uh
i had always assumed that somebody i
knew that well we were just gonna do it
in person
you know um but obviously
not able to do that now um he is
i i think the best talker i know the
best talker i've ever met
well so that's why this was we were so
excited i was so excited to do this and
just to catch up with a friend um but
knowing that he is a friend who is
beyond gifted at telling stories and uh
spinning a yarn very important person in
your life yeah
and um i think he's a pretty important
person in a lot of people's lives
because he's brought so much joy to
the world talking to him like
all these nights started flooding back
um
that i feel so grateful to have had just
the laughter and my face would hurt you
know like we'd
hang out till whatever hour in the
morning and your face would hurt the
next day from laughing like those face
those muscles that you're not that used
to
using as much as you do
just smiling so much um
and everyone knows him that you've seen
his movies uh he is in person just the
the quickest his mind is just so sharp
he's one of the most fascinating people
i know yeah
i think wedding crashers is the is the
best comedy of the millennium so far is
that uh i know that's a big statement i
i think so too i
it's it's definitely of the that first
decade i think it was the best the best
studio movie studio comedy and i
remember one night being at uh
forgive me this is name drop you i know
but uh sean penn had kind of cornered
vince
not in a threatening way but was uh
was talking to him for a while and i i
afterwards and and it looked like they
were being very serious you know they
were in a in
locked in this serious talk and
afterwards vince just basically said he
was uh
talking all about wedding crashers he
was going on about how what a brilliant
movie he thought it was how he thought
vince should be nominated and stuff and
i remember at the time thinking like
nominated for uh but the more i watch
that movie um the more i agree with sean
penn i think that those performances
vince's in particular is um
really special it's it's what he's doing
in that movie is uh
unlike anything else and go watch his
movie
freaky freaky one two three freaky
it looks great and he looks really funny
that he's playing um it's a body swap
movie so he's
there's a like a college age girl in his
body like a teenage girl who is in his
body also personal to us we just and i
with our friend kier
um a few years back
wrote a movie called a case of you and
in order to get it made in order to
finish getting financing
vince came on to do a day on it and
allowed us to make the movie and yeah
obviously he didn't have to do it i
think we're both appreciative it was for
that it was just really kind
completely unnecessary young for him to
do but it was like 10 pages of dialogue
remember that it was a lot he did so
much and it was it was like overwritten
yes it didn't have to be ten pages no
and he's so smart and good with he's
such a good writer he's so quick on his
feet that he also took the time the
night before to go through and kind of
pare it down so it would be um just
better and the best lines that he has in
the movie are his like he came up with i
one that i still remember is um that's
what he does his mind is so unique and
sharp that he comes up with lines that
end up being like iconic you know but he
has uh he says something in there when
he says goodbye to me he plays my agent
who's like overly uh effusive and stuff
and he says um okay bye-bye
instead of saying i love you he says x's
and o's
triple x's triple h that's right that's
right i can't even get his line right
it's yeah
a lot of that stuff he comes up with the
wedding crashers he came up with
motorboating right here
a lot of that is just from his brain and
a lot of his thrown away lines a lot of
his asides they're simple they're like
uh i i think about when he says to the
the the waiters um at the parties at the
weddings uh okay are you gonna circle
back around are you about the
fingerprints it got some nice finger
foods you get in your hands it's a
phenomenal fingerprint oh yeah yeah
that's all him like get your hands on
this you gotta get your hands on so i go
go grab that net and catch yourself a
nice baby you know let's hear the real
thing i know okay the real oh hey come
in for the real thing that's him come on
in for the real thing i hope you're all
sitting down you're ready for
my catch-up with my
my dear friend um and one of my favorite
actors
vince vaughn life could be a dream
[Music]
hey buddy oh man thanks for doing this
i'm glad to be sitting with you dude
good to see you what are you have you
been doing a lot of press
i have been but not a lot like this i've
been doing um
kind of the zoom
uh
press chunk at both domestic and
internationally and you know you feel
you feel so dishonest because
they ask you the same questions and then
you have to make it as if like you're
giving that answer you you know that
feeling right oh yeah yeah and
do you ever play the game you may have
taught me this game where you where you
have to come up with a word or a phrase
yeah like a phrase that's so odd that
you have to fit in
you know where we started that even
prior to that like i love cinnamon i
don't know about you but i love cinnamon
you know where we started that was even
prior to the junkets
was um
when i was with peter billingsley out in
public
at first he was not always you know to
go up to someone you don't know is
always an uncomfortable proposition
so i would say i would give him
something that was so crazy and
non-separated that you'd have to fit in
and then then it became kind of like
you know going up and saying hi was not
complicated but but having to fit in the
thing and there would be stuff like i'm
sorry if i i'm sorry if i'm i'm
squinting a lot it's just that i was up
really late last night painting
miniature elves that's right right
i remember that before it would be
something like you know i get
uncomfortable around people or new
surroundings but when i do i just
picture myself and everyone else
swimming naked with dolphins and i can
take i could take that deep breath that
i need
you so so peter or somebody else would
have to go up and and work that into the
conversation and do a conversation with
yeah never back off of it or apologize
for it right like and you'd be surprised
how people are usually fairly
accommodating to be like oh well that's
great you have a hobby you know what i
mean like yeah
yeah did do you ever remember it
backfiring and people being like that's
a weird thing to say because i remember
i if you i remember you two
like doing that with somebody and if as
long as you set it in like a an affable
friendly way people will kind of accept
most things i had a friend when i was
younger that was in his 80s that was an
ex-comedy writer he used to write
stand-up for like phyllis diller and
stuff right he was like a joke man that
was always coming up with one-liners
and he was old enough that he was tired
he only liked to talk about what he
liked to talk about
he was kind of cranky and he enjoyed
being a contrarian but i remember
sitting with him at restaurants
and he would say like we would go to
jerry's deli in the valley uh-huh this
is back like in late dailies early 90s
and he would say
you know you can say things publicly
really loudly and people and there's so
much noise going on in a restaurant they
won't even be able to
recognize what you're saying
if it even like scream out like a swear
word like uh-huh loud but then just keep
talking and selling me on the idea that
nobody could really track what he was
saying
did you notice that people didn't really
care it was odd he would he would say it
really loud but then he would get a
lovely like delicious smile on his face
like he took a cookie he shouldn't have
just keep explaining his theory and it
was odd because i think there's so much
going on and people wouldn't expect it
but then if someone did hear it like
would you just think that he had
a motivation or was he mad at who he was
sitting with and then they didn't want
to get involved in a domestic dispute i
don't know justin it's
how do you meet a guy like that how do
you get to know how i just love that
you're friends with that guy you were
young then you were like a 20 year old
yeah you know i was my grandmother was
raised in the house with me um
she had gotten bad arthritis so she was
raised with me and i used to joke with
her like crazy we had so much fun and
she was part of a senior citizen group
even when i was younger like junior high
in high school i would go with her
and hang with the seniors
and they would go to like an event at
like a baseball game it would be all of
us on a bus
and i always found the seniors to be
great they were so smart and really warm
comfortable with all ages so when i met
when i met phil he was a guy who showed
up by himself and we were all joking and
we would just include him and it was a
weird deal i remember
there was some odd he was he was great
we ended up going over and hanging out
at his apartment sometimes but at first
he was real reluctant to make a
friendship and then he was like the warm
softies well he must have loved you i
mean you're also like so good with
it's
him he was so funny
yeah he was hilarious you're like that
too you've always had friends of
different ages i love i'm very close
with my grandmother who's sassy and
she's got a an edge she's 103. vince
that reminds me of
she's 103. that's why you look that's
why you still look like a 19 year old
you're absolutely gorgeous i wish this
wasn't live streaming and people could
see this porcelain face you possess it's
unbelievable
i mean you you you've always been that
way and sneaky justin's always been like
the funniest the most considerate always
right
oh so aware and include people and then
he takes off his shirt that's like hello
all right well
we're gonna have to cut that out uh look
at it by the way i wore this shirt for
you i wore a chicago um
i've had this since in fifth grade is
that a special livestream
yeah michael jordan and spike lee got to
be used
the the um
the that scene that you're describing in
a restaurant with with phil uh and now
i'm thinking about swingers the scene in
swingers that you don't seem like
somebody who would
you strike me as somebody who wouldn't
get embarrassed by stuff like that
or would you ever i think me and you are
similar where
i
i like human nature
i like to have fun
and sometimes socially it's just
interesting to play around with dynamics
but you know if you think we're similar
in that
when you when you become funny or you
have a sense of humor and part of that
is you know not being great at all
things so essentially who serves you
well you know yeah i think you learn at
a young age like if you hurt someone's
feelings or make someone sad that feels
terrible
so you learn how to not do that and then
it sort of becomes more about like
creating a fun experience for everyone
like me you and rockwell
we used to go to the chateau with peter
and i mean there was never more fun than
we would just write bits and do charades
and oh man
i remember roping mike myers mike myers
was sitting by do you remember this he
was sitting by himself at the chat and
sam was like
that's mike meyer you know we should we
should talk to him we should tell him so
we did like sam and i went up and we
were big fans and and you know he's very
canadian and mild-mannered and he was
like oh thanks and he we invited him to
hang out you were doing elvis bits mike
came over and he started we roped him
into some of the
stick we were doing and he he tapped out
after like an hour he was like this is
too much right
i can't keep up with this [ __ ]
we had a full appetite first
we were fascinated though because elvis
was so handsome and had the voice of an
opera singer yeah and he was so popular
that when he started to introduce
taekwondo or karate
into both his live stage act in his
movies
no one was able to say to him like this
is weird like yeah like why are you
throwing roundhouse kicks and stuff in
the middle of a song but then the oddity
that fascinated us was he was also so
[ __ ] cool
yeah it kind of was cool
yeah you don't it's not weird he's too
cool he uh
if anyone else were to do that it'd be
like noticeably weird weird but but his
queens were someone was a towny
someone was elvis
the townie would be disrespectful to a
lady
elvis would go out of his way to be
cordial
and well i you point you and if you
remember the line i tried to remember it
because i knew we were talking with
something like you put this jack rabbit
in a corner he's going to
find his way out is that what it was
yeah i think so that's sam's favorite
line you'll put this driver
man he's going to find his way out let's
dance and then you'd start throwing and
then it's happening with your last
chance real shitty and then get and then
get beaten up yeah
but i usually had to end up being the
lady i was cast as the lady quite often
true you were elvis bunny weren't you
so you'd hand out roles uh
it was so shakespearean it was an homage
to theater of old justin we we were
ahead of our time we were woke back
before people were awake awakening i
just don't think any girls wanted to do
improv no no
no that's when you'd lose them
when you did that same elvis bit
the 40th time in the in a row there was
just no
no participating actresses well it would
be i remember there was maybe if there
was any interest even if it was like
mild interest
from someone from a lady it would yeah
it would soon dissipate it'd be like oh
these guys are just doing this bit all
night okay i'm going to go have fun with
my face we're not doing this pizza good
to know us they're doing this bit no
matter who's around
this is for an audience of zero of three
of us three yeah yeah yeah
but but people think i mean people also
uh but you did have i remember you also
would have really close
girlfriends like lady like friends who
were girls like you you hung out a lot
with god i used to love watching you and
janine garofalo go at it like um i love
you she's so funny and sweet uh you guys
were both so smart and funny and
you would you know whether it was
politics or whatever it was it was just
so entertaining to watch you guys and
also you're always lovely to talk about
stuff with because you have you know
strong conventions and you've thought
about stuff but but i think all of us
could hear other ideas and make light of
it which was fun but it was nice like
those coffee shop conversations you
could talk about a movie or anything in
different points of view and
that was so much of the fun of it i
think is having engaged people to talk
about stuff with and everyone care about
it yeah
where you could still laugh at
yourselves yeah i would never get it
would never get negative it would never
get uh and if it did i remember at what
i remember once it did start getting a
little heated between you and janine and
you
put the lid on i mean you had a way of
just kind of like easing people when
when when you sensed it going there it's
interesting that you say you don't like
to make people
you hurt people you know you learn at an
early age you don't want to hurt that
you know it's funny huh and then you
look over and the one guy is not
laughing and it feels terrible and i
have a lot of friends who were in the
comedy and improv and would really be
hard on themselves if you felt that they
did it at the expense of something
[Music]
it's like you could i don't know what it
is maybe because we were so kind of
insecure in some ways younger yeah that
you were just so heightened at
recognizing like a terminator what is
the thing that they think no one's
noticing
yeah you know what i mean and you could
do it in a way where everyone's having
fun and they're not and then you learn
like oh i they're not prepared for that
i don't have to go that far
exactly yeah i i can
take my foot off the gas a little bit
and still have the same comedic effect
like i it's interesting you say
terminator because that's how you always
struck me when you would not in a i'm
going to get you way but in um
in a comedic i'm going to get you away
i'm going to kind of like flip the
script on you and you started doing it
in movies you started using the lines
that you would use when we were hanging
out and i have such nerdy questions
about where specifically some of these
lines came from
like um
like stuff in wedding crashers a lot of
that was improvised right like the uh
the motorboat
i've done it with you so many times but
you know you you have something on paper
and a lot of times you'll go through the
scene and we'll just rewrite it yeah you
know if you have a confident director
who allows you know who's who's into
this we're clapping you did that with
the breakup right i remember before we
started so many great ideas for that
character and fun things to do and then
and then
you know you'll do the lines but
sometimes we change the lines before we
got there and then if we had it in the
can
why not play around a little bit anyway
but you were always good and you're
terrific at it at that advancing story
you know keeping a mind on what needs to
happen in the scene is important i
learned that from you i mean there was
no one who taught me that lesson uh
better than you did and i remember
specifically a scene in dodgeball when
in the story it was after we lost the
game and it looked like things were
falling apart and we were shooting a
scene where we were all kind of
grab-assing and like doing bits in
between takes and i remember you just
being really kind of like
not participating in that which was
unusual and
i don't know you were very focused and
you said to me
you made the point that this was a
serious scene i used to think of
comedies as being like well this is all
fun i mean it is fun but like you
it was the first time i realized that
you really had to commit to the story no
matter what the genre was and and you
were doing that like better than anyone
i'd ever seen do you remember this it
was yeah you know i think what it was is
i had done some improv younger on stage
with the improv olympic not for long but
i was fortunate that they put me
up and performing very quickly and that
experience of doing it live is
invaluable because you start to learn
like if it's not on story like if it's a
herald which is something where they
they give you a subject and you start
creating scenes with your partners and
story lines
if it's something that veers off of the
theme even if it's funny it doesn't have
traction
right and if you don't take and
sometimes comedy is an over commitment
to the absurd
you know why not this movie even
dodgeball and how funny you are but also
so warm and lovable
because what you care about are innocent
things and you're so
invested but it's funny but it's also
kind of heartwarming you know yeah yeah
so i think
i think sometimes on set it's it's a
balance and everyone has to find their
way it's good to joke and keep it light
but there's also times i think to
stay in it
yeah honor the process and and just stay
in it and it just depends on the scene
and on your confidence level i guess
yeah you you had also said something
like um at the time something else that
was invaluable which is to not go
looking for the jokes you know to not go
to not veer too far off course
uh
in an attempt to do it make a funny to
have a funny line to kind of stay true
to the intention of the scene that was
something else it's the same as method
acting or any acting that it's it's the
lines are yes but
but the intentions or the life behind it
is actually the most valuable and that
comes from listening
and reacting or being available to react
honestly to something that someone says
not having a plan thing
uh-huh so i think that to some degree if
i'm just thinking of what's the craziest
thing i can say right it may be
authentic based off of what the person
said prior to so sometimes an improv my
favorite stuff is like when people don't
say anything you're a great setup guy
two people might not think of you that
way and
jake johnson reminds me a lot of that
when i was working with jake johnson he
has this thing where he can he's just a
great listener and he loves
setting people up and it's and
oftentimes it might his favorite improvs
like yours are
very simple thing you know it's it's i'm
sorry what did you say or uh i'm
thinking about the stuff and made where
you're making favreau laugh i mean it's
those those outtakes which i love
watching where he can't get through a
take uh
and the stuff that you're doing is is
all on story it's all story stuff um
that's why he's like i he's just
brilliant stuff i think it's fun
sometimes it's fun to see someone's
point of view on something that's right
isn't that what it is to something right
that someone
can have that much conviction in a way
that's that's not that's a little left
of normal yeah but believable
yeah it's a weird thing to keep it
within that drawn thing on speaking of
dodgeball i remember
and i've told this before that i can't
rosten was i think he was a division
three quarterback and yes they would
have it not a starter although that was
not
as known but anyway
he was really big on trying to really
whip the ball and throw the ball you
know and it's a film but this was the
rosten's the director and rosten is so
um fun and got a great energy and social
year-round and makes it like a game and
fun
but he had like kind of a jock energy
where it was like really about going for
it
like came in one day they had a speed
ball machine
that they were putting dodge balls in
that would be like a fast pitch machine
and
i came in there
to take one this thing was turned up so
[ __ ] high
and i remember hitting me and being like
in this old show pony meaning myself
having having jumped some gates before
said
oh this is never gonna like no one's
gonna know whether this thing's going 87
miles an hour or 60. what is
what would be the purpose of this thing
being cranked up that high so it hit me
and i took like
you know like the like the senior actor
on the set point of view and i was like
this is dangerous
nobody should be in front of this
machine i said this is crazy the fact
that like i would come in and and
everyone would assume this was okay
what i didn't realize was that the
fabulous jay long had already taken
about 80 balls to the face
at the highest [ __ ] speed you were
out there just getting bloodied and
butchered in the face for the funny
well be well it's uh it illustrates how
um eager i was some may say desperate
um if they can commit it i say committed
i say committed
no i don't
i took the wind out of my normal rama
[Laughter]
my norma ray moment i don't think they
let me drive home that day they were
concerned about me driving that day i
was driving myself to that on that job
and um
and they said hey justin somebody had
moved my car you know transpo guy and
when they gave me my keys back before
they gave them back they said there was
a producer i forget i think it was
rhodes and he said hey um
are you okay to drive
my response was like just a half second
behind you know i was like
what do you mean
and that was before people were really
aware of concussions
yes yeah i was a trailblazer
you were a groundblaster dude
that job was the best i um it was so fun
being around you but but before we had
done that job we like you said we were
hanging out and um
i remember just the laughs that we would
have and
i remember during that time this is like
the early 2000s i had a theory that you
were doing so many serious jobs at the
time do you remember you were doing like
i think you just come back from like
domestic disturbance maybe you
that you just want you had all this
funny in you
and it wasn't coming out it was it
didn't have a place to go and then
you started doing comedies again uh old
school and stuff and and you were now
you now had a place for it uh what do
you think of my theory what's funny is i
think for all of us as actors
i had done swingers in that in may but i
was doing more
you know still i was more drawn to
character stuff and independence yeah
and i was doing stuff that was you know
clay pigeons cliche comedy and it
returned to paradise and really fun
movies that i was proud of but
it was interesting this the studios did
not think of me as a as a mainstream
comedy actor because i had never done
those i mean swingers was well liked by
the people in the industry but but you
know meaning the other actors and stuff
is as comedic with you know with the
drama kind of i guess not broad comedy
anyway um and it was really todd
phillips who had to push for me to be an
old school but interesting enough on
dodgeball i remember a lot everyone was
playing that movie so broad in a great
way
and i remember i was getting a lot of
pressure
from some of the some of the brass like
not vince is not like yucking it up and
going broad and i remember i had a
conversation with you and my theory was
kind of an old one which was if i'm the
lead and i'm the narrator the guy that
you're seeing the movie through
every if the world around me is broad i
have to be someone that holds the
emotion together in so much as that you
know how to take these other characters
i have to stay grounded meaning the same
man in the insane world
whereas it's gonna be the crazy
character the world around you
traditionally needs to be more normal
right everyone if everyone is is crazy
then what's your way in you need dorothy
as my point to walk through oz because
if the 10 man goes to oz you have no
bearings
i really felt very confident in kind of
playing that character with a point of
view and having a a style and a an
authenticness that would help carry the
movie and as it
bore out thankfully it sort of held
together and worked well and you you
ended up being right about it but where
did that come like how did you know to
do that like i know to do that now i
learned that lesson from you from people
like you i remember sam pointing that
out he said that's what bill murray does
um movies like meatballs and stuff he
and you allowed stiller i mean stiller
is
phenomenal in that movie so funny in
that as he is in most things but like
you said bra i mean that character is
ridiculous
i remember even like they wanted you to
like do stuff from swinger you know wink
more and be more
jokey kind of stuff more uh
how did you know to fight that how did
you know i think anytime
you've gone and investigated stuff and
comedy particular it's just in any sort
of movie it's sort of an old adage that
if the world is so bizarre you need
alice to win alice in wonderland you
know so
i knew it was being funny and having a
fun point of view and and a guy that was
likable but you know flawed that we've
seen that type of archetype before and
thankfully everyone around was so funny
it all really worked but i remember like
sometimes when you get people
with comedy as you know they think a
banana pill is funny potentially or just
you scott like you know you see this
with posters a lot they try so hard to
convey into comedy
right
yeah i'm doing that like crosstalk yeah
like back to back so hard guys that what
they're actually saying is this is just
really broad you know versus other
posters that that aren't trying to
convey everything visually
but before we get off of dodgeball we
have to share a little bit
how me and you stayed at rap for an
extra two days
the last weekend in vegas of uh v vaughn
and jay
we had fun in vegas but we had fun in
like me and you decided to stay and it
was so
fun and but we were doing like there was
a lot of social experience we got so far
in our own little bits and games that it
was so crazy
right
well we started doing a thing uh where
where as we would pass somebody we would
just say oh it started with each other
oh right before we got our confidence to
include strangers it started with each
other
it was so yeah yeah we would just start
saying oh we were playing blackjack and
stuff and we would say
oh
and then kind of right the response was
as if you were surprised
yeah and slightly turned on
by what the other person was doing
so even though
oh was this suggests that it was
surprising you didn't see it coming but
also
that there was kind of an you were sort
of attracted to what the person yeah and
then it evolved to one hand
one hand
gently grinding around the other
person's face like you were stroking
your face
and it was all in response to something
really mundane like should we maybe eat
some dinner oh oh
a face rub and there's also a way like
if either of us were getting passionate
about an idea you would
take the legs out from underneath the
other person by kind of like making it
like oh you're just attractive and let
me let me strike your face it was almost
condescending
yeah it was a way to just stop them
but now
we were not sleeping very much and if
you know this coincided with the rodeo
the national championship rodeo do you
remember that
yes yeah we had watched football great
the rodeo's in town so me and you were
like suburban kids
on a flannel and then
and then we would go to like i don't
even remember we were going to events
for the rodeo
well i remember we went to some
bar somebody because we were asking
around hey where the rodeo's in town
where where's the place to go and so
somebody directed us to some some
honky-tonk themed bar and and they got
excited you were there and so they they
were like they ushered us over to
remember this the vip area but there was
it was the craziest vip thing i've ever
seen in my life now i
as you know i'm a huge country western
fan i love you yes music my grandfather
was a had it was a dairy farmer and a
real road worker so i like i like that
stuff you introduced me to dwight yoakam
and bucko
mega talented and a female
but the vip in this was interesting
because go ahead describe what this was
like we got to get you to the vip area
we were like okay
it was kind of in the middle of the area
and it was it was elevated i think just
by one step right maybe two but it was
elevated and um there was a rope around
it and maybe some hay scattered about to
kind of affect a stable feel like a
country
and um but we so we were the only ones
in there but there was no walls justin
it was almost like a circular what would
be a horse a place one would tie their
horse in the old west
because there was no walls not to see
who's in the vip
it was like what you would was a horse
to in front of a saloon in a western
although it was circular and surrounded
by those troughs so we were and there
was only like a stream like a stream
that's right then we were now standing
in the middle of the place
fully on display
in front of us with nothing it was like
it was like we couldn't have been like
in a position to stick out even more
yeah exactly
it's so much fun but especially you
because as it is i remember walking
through the casino floors with you and i
remember you saying like before we went
there you know because we had gone out
in l.a and stuff and like you'd get
recognized because you were also very
tough you know you people don't realize
how tall you are in vegas it's even on
top of that there was so much like
swingers there's so much like oh my
people would lose their minds when they
saw you because you were kind of like
part of the vegas experience for them
you know
but you know is that we went out we went
then we went out at night somewhere
wasn't there a nighttime concert we went
to yeah it was uh i think no longer a
country western theme it became a kind
of a hip-hop
it was a combination of lots of things
yeah anyway after being up all night the
last night and then having to go catch
our plane we had gotten to a point when
we were having conversations
where we would pass people we didn't
know
and we would say the o line and we would
stroke them
so we were passing people as we were
talking like oh this is interesting i
wonder how the scene will cut what do
you got going on yeah then we would just
pass someone you know without a couple a
couple of guys they could be they could
be they could be bikers they could be
stock brokers it could be whatever and
we would go oh
as if we were surprised to see them and
sometimes we would just like an ear
stroke next to them but we
at first it was fun it became such a
habit we wouldn't even look to see how
they responded we must have done it 20
times i remember before we got on the
plane we went to a fast food restaurant
to order yeah
people were taking our orders people in
line and just like it was so strange no
one really responded
yeah i remember uh get ordering like a
breakfast sandwich and uh oh and they'd
say what would you want any coffee with
that oh
and we would do it there
like they had said something suggestive
yeah we started doing it where it was
just so i was like you were surprised
and you were you were you were receiving
you were receiving a an advance from
them it's so crazy
and then we just flew on our plane i
think you sat a seat in front of me for
some reason yeah
we had one a game two didn't we i think
oh yeah we won
oh my gosh you're right we we bet on
foot and we bet on the game we won and i
never we never cashed in and you go
we'll do it you know it's not a big deal
we'll do it next time we want something
parlay it was like a three or four team
parlay yeah but we were gonna miss the
flight but that was such a fun way to
finish that shoot with to have that
that weekend we had so much we went to
like oh yeah
i was gambling
at i was gambling i i you know my dad
was a big card player so i always grew
up gambling and that kind of stuff and
but i remember i knew how to play poker
and how to do stuff so we were gambling
the right the high enough amounts so we
would go to like the nicest restaurants
yeah and order like everything
and we had so much fun dude you were
such a blast
god that was fun
that was so [ __ ] fun i uh
do you go back to vegas still do you
ever go back go back sometimes i go with
my wife and and that and or some friends
and i'll go and just for a couple
weekends to gamble but this was this was
a this was like the the end of a shoot
yeah it was such we were like it was
like a vision quest we were on
right
it was like a vision question it was
like being yeah it was an odyssey we
talked about everything one could speak
of in the world yeah yeah it was
reflecting on the movie
yeah right it was yeah the right way was
someone who you love to finish this
experience and kind of digest everything
because as an actor sometimes especially
early on you're left alone to kind of
think about
how you feel true
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
and then we had the experience with all
of your
other friends kyra was involved on the
wild west comedy tour that was that had
a similar vibe right about in terms of
like hanging out and you know sharing
story laughing i mean we just laughed so
much on that i was only with you guys in
the beginning and the end but uh
what game what gave you the why how did
that come together why did you end up
doing something like that you know i had
friends that were stand-ups
at the time stand-up comedy although
it's gone through ways but it wasn't as
today it's so popular i think partially
because
studios are so afraid to make a comedy
with a point of view and obviously
in comedy even if the points of view
don't have to be things that anyone
agrees with but a strong point of view
is is funny and and and
now a lot of comedians you know you talk
about the text
thread that we're on bill burr being one
of them who's a friend of both of ours
who's terrific
um
i love that he has strong points of
views on stuff and so i think yeah
really go to stand up because they're
looking to laugh and
and and be funny but and the movies
aren't doing aren't taking strong points
of view as much um
you know those types of filmmakers that
did that we don't now the comedies are
more trying to include everybody you
know
versus versus taking characters that are
that are that are you know askew and
you're laughing at their points of view
so even trent even your character in
swinger is the end uh you know you do a
lot of things in that movie that
character does things in that movie that
could be construed as uh offensive or
maybe
abrasive or whatever it is but you get
your comeuppance at the end you you are
i guess i felt different in trent in so
much as in that movie in general i think
one of the things that we did right in
that was
in high school or in college if you're
around girls and classes you get to know
them and you it's easy to say hi and you
have time to hang out and be friends and
right but if you're if you're not around
girls in a social setting you have to
learn how to go up to somebody which is
scary you know how do you go up to
someone you don't know
and break the ice to see if you get
along
and it becomes a thing of like how do
you do that so you're dealing with a
breakup or a guy who's hurting over a
breakup it's not like he could have any
girl he's hurt
he's moving on in his life and he's
trying to figure out like how do i have
self value and go to connect with people
so if you really listen to what prince
says a lot in the movie is
it's kind of empowering of his friend
he's not cutting girls down he's not
teaching him how to be mean he says your
money
and you got to let him know that you
want to have fun right he's building
them up about the girls and like making
them feel bad or getting them to doubt
themselves it's all sort of right
positive exchanges you know of course
young you're not completely evolved so i
think why the characters liked it in the
movies he's a good friend to mikey you
can tell he really does like him he
stands up for him he's really trying
just to build him up and tell him he's
worth loving that he's worth that he can
date someone and the great lesson of the
movie is to be yourself because if
you're not yourself you're really not
connecting with somebody in a way where
they like you you're putting on some
kind of a presentation right right and
that's what he i think the thing at the
end was an added on thing john actually
didn't want it in the movie originally
oh really i was coming back from chicago
i went home to before we filmed and i
was sitting in the airport
i was sitting in a seat and there was
the ticket counter that i could see the
line was like um going towards the
counter and there was a man but he
started waving and smiling at me like in
a way that was like treating me like
like a cute little teddy bear and it was
a strange moment because it was very i
didn't know this person and it was so
confidently done
i thought this is an odd thing like it's
one thing to wink or smile at someone
but this guy's really like waving at me
and blowing me kisses and [ __ ] like and
and this is before you had a known face
no one knew me yeah i had yeah yeah
guest spots and stuff but yeah i
remember like going through a gamut like
do i just ignore him do i look back at
him like i'm a tough guy don't don't
play around with me like how did i make
this stop because
i felt harris
he didn't stop it happened about four or
five times it was the craziest thing
ever
and so then once he exchanged his ticket
he began to walk directly at me and i
thought this gentleman is the most
confident condescending person and then
a couple rolls before me he stopped he
like bent down you know and i couldn't
tell because the head of the child did
not come up above it he was he was
entertaining a baby that's so amazing he
was in line so the kid didn't cry and i
shared it with john
and so then we created the scene where
uh
the fun of the movie and that idea was
that
you know
some of those independent films they had
some idea and then at some point someone
would explain the entire movie verbally
which always felt right the movie didn't
work if someone has to explain what the
movie was
right that's an odd choice so we're sort
of making fun or having fun with those
expectations that
at the end when me and him are talking
he starts to say something like you know
what man i didn't understand it and then
it hit me so it's like
like okay now he's going to explain
the message of the film
oh that's right but then it's like no
we're not doing that
but then it became me
being engaged with
the woman
you got off of that
and in a way what you're saying in a fun
way at the end is sort of like there's a
lot of levels what that what that
suggests and then you know mike is sort
of resolved he looks out the window
he's right over searching for coaching
or things his ego is by being himself
and being comfortable with himself and
not trying
that's a great way to connect with
someone so i think why swingers is
surviving is i think that and this is
true in in most stories or movies or all
of us in life is we're not inventing
anything we're revealing what's already
there
in this case what you're sort of getting
at like in a socratic way i don't think
any of us in any of these conversations
get through all the way is that
being yourself and being genuine with
someone
is more intimate and a better way to
have a connection because someone can
really love you and if you're presenting
things that you think someone is going
to like well then you're not really
they're not giving them a chance to get
to know who you are well and what a
great lesson uh and that's when that's
what that scene with heather graham is
so good when he just kind of like lets
his guard down he's like you know what
i'm just gonna start uh and he just
starts being honest and there's yeah he
says you know she goes oh i thought real
men don't like key she's like my
reputation precedes me he's not putting
on facades he's not trying
and that's when you actually have the
connection which is also good writing
that
what was different about swingers was if
you really look at the messaging was
not about you know getting someone to
question themselves or false race stuff
it was really go up there feeling like
there's nothing wrong with dating go up
right you're worth dating and a little
bit of like you know don't be so
desperate a little bit of push and pull
between in a relationship is a good
thing you know not to be right it's a
dance
so there's a truism and an innocence to
swingers and i think with trent
you know trent is clearly not a guy
looking to make people feel small
right cut them down you know and that's
a terrible way in
in any sort of friendship or
relationship because if you do that and
they go along with it you can't really
respect them you know what i mean it's
not going to go well in the long run
those those relationships will never
survive
or you can't really respect yourself
because you try to be petty and make
someone feel less so how do you how do
you feel good about yourself right it
comes from a place of unhappiness too
and and a lack of worth and you that's
it lack of worth is really it you know
you see it in all things it's like it's
one thing if someone has something and
you're like gosh i wish i had that but
i'm happy for them it's another thing
where it's like i don't have it i wish
they didn't let me get let me get them
to doubt themselves or
right that's a terrible that's a
terrible emotion to give over to you
strike me as
somebody who always was able to have
friends who were actors because you
didn't give in to jealousy or i mean
this is even before you were you were
successful as an actor right you had a
lot of like
that's kind of the nice thing with our
group of friends to some degree is like
i love acting and we're all sort of
excited by movies so it's so fun to be
excited for people doing stuff and also
like in a weird way when you start off
as an actor
there's a false idea
that
you and this person are in competition
not not that there's not you know trying
out for parts and not that competition
is good but what you come to realize is
you're actually a part of a strange
group that only these other people can
relate to that's you know what i mean
like which bonds to be more supportive
of each other because you know what it's
like to screen test three times and
knock it apart totally you know what
it's like to go to a set and then not
get to your coverage when you're
starting you know what i mean so
these guys are actually my family
they're not my they're not my
adversaries they're actually the people
that i'm sharing this journey with well
it's and funny vince there's no better
example of that in my life than which
you facilitated which was my friendship
with keir which started as kira
o'donnell who who played todd in wedding
crushers it started with
i was so insanely i don't know if
jealous is the right word because i
didn't know kyr um but i wanted that
wedding crasher so badly you know i'd
read fortnite uh and and cure ended up
getting i remember thinking who is this
guy who's who got this part that was
supposed to be my and uh and you would
call me when you guys were shooting and
say you gotta come meet this kid you got
you guys would like each other you were
trying to set us up as a friend set us
up and i wanted nothing to do with it
and i was sort of jealous that he was
you know that you guys were getting to
hang out so when i met him i just you
know we fell in love with each other we
were just friends right away but um
he uh he would tell me stories about
wedding crashers which is
i think the best movie the funniest
movie made of that decade um
and and the one i wanted to ask you
about was uh was the dinner table scene
that that scene he said it took did it
did that take three weeks to shoot did
that take um
he just told me how complicated it was
like the breakup dinner table scene was
the same animal michael higgins right
both love is no one's funnier than
michael higgins by the way
good luck improvising with him right he
is so quick and fun so quick yeah well
you know you're matching these energies
and then it's the next day or two days
later you're getting to the reaction on
the other side and same with crashers
it's like you know and dopken's a great
director and you're going around a table
with multiple people
and you're matching these extreme
moments and it's hard to maintain that
energy sometimes it's its own technical
discipline as an actor to be able to
deliver that and be there off camera for
your fellow actors
right yeah god i can't imagine it
because you watch it
and i've done those dinner table scenes
but people might not know how much
uh it's just brilliant that
yeah just brilliant um
what was uh i also want to ask you go
back before the act and you had told a
great story
do you remember what you used to used to
get into amusement parks you had you had
a a thing that you would do where you
would you would get tickets from like uh
disney world disney and stuff were you
will you tell that story yes
so when i was younger
i had become friendly with the kid
he was actually a boyfriend of one of my
older sisters a guy named i won't i
won't say his name but he was he was
really kind and really great to me
but he had a really unique background he
lived in a trailer park his mom lived in
the trailer with her parents the
grandparents
and he was 16 when i met him i went to
go see him in the trailer park and the
grandparents were not particularly
affectionate to him
he didn't get to sleep there
and he he would have to pay them a
quarter to use the shower and at the
time there was two young girls that were
about you know just over a year apart
but they each had different fathers and
what became clear was that the mother
i had multiple children
i want to say potentially north of 10
and with different dads all the time and
so the grandparents feeling close to
each kid he was really kind and loving
but really tough like
total survivor and interesting because
a lot of guys like this
he he didn't have a dad his father i
think was in some kind of serious crime
and lived in florida it was so bad he
ran away from his father
i didn't realize this but he hitchhiked
everywhere he had gotten a tent that he
would put in woods to sleep at night
i remember going out to eat with him and
my sister at like a restaurant and then
him asking us to wait outside and then
later realizing
that he never paid like he found a way
to walk into places without getting
recognized i remember him going to
grocery stores he would walk around
and make a sandwich in the store why
talking to security
wow into people and being like it's
normal
because it's just how he survived he
would yeah this was before you would
there was bleeps like when you would
take something out of a store so yeah
walk
in his hand
and his thought process was if they
stopped him he would just say oh i
forgot it was an oh yeah but if you put
it on your shirt it was a thing so
anyway he was very much a guy who would
survive he had nothing the other side
that i found fascinating was he would
watch a lot of kung fu movies
he would take adages or sayings
and he was looking for some fatherly
parental guidance
know so he would repeat these things
over and over like they were words
mantras he also had nunchucks that he
would keep
um in the back of his jeans so if you
frisk them you wouldn't know he had it
on him and he was so protective of my
sister and he was very loving and sweet
he was very strong i remember it was
crazy he would come over to our house
and have a bandage around his stomach he
was stabbed in a fight he just didn't
have any guidance justin he was very
loving and sweet
he was so interesting to me and my dad
is so honest and such a my dad is
hilarious but my dad's the kind of guy
like if the dealer mispays him at the
blackjack table
he'll say no you paid me too much and
give it back to the dealer he's a hard
worker he's an honest hard worker yeah
like i remember my dad my dad was
selling a house and a guy had to put
down like you know ten thousand or
twenty thousand dollar deposit and when
the deal didn't go through even though
my dad was allowed to keep it my dad
gave it back to him wow
why did you do that that he said well if
he can't afford the house fence do you
think he can afford the money and my dad
was became very successful he was the
first to go through college but
my dad is so in his gran his mom was the
same way so honest
yeah yeah but i remember thinking of it
i think a lot of us that that is as a
game so i became very good at getting
into bars when i wasn't old enough and
getting into places i didn't belong and
it became the fun it was fun to go
places you didn't go
and when i first moved to hollywood i
moved out when i was 18.
peter lived with me billingsly
and i remember when it came to get
alcohol what i would do and it's
something i learned from this from this
gentleman
is
we would go to the grocery store
you would get a shopping cart
in the shopping cart you would put like
a like bologna and some bread you know
you would pay for the sandwich then
you'd go to the liquor department and
you would put like bottles of
vodka
you would put like cases of beer
underneath the shopping cart
on the bottom
right this is before there was bleeps
and tax cuz you were trying to get
alcohol you were underage right right
yeah remember as a kid sometimes we'd go
to like a town and give like navy guys
money to buy a spare and sometimes they
would just take the money and sometimes
you're gonna do that spot for beer and
sometimes yeah i didn't give it to you
right yeah because this was our solve
and then when you would push out of the
store you would just talk really fun to
the woman who was checking it out of
course because of the way it was
positioned they couldn't see what was on
the bottom of the cart and then walking
out you would like go up to the security
guard and talk to him you know just
sneak out in a hurry yeah
you were bracing with the bottom of the
car you know booze to go out of my way
go to the security guard and have a
conversation with them so this is how we
would get alcohol we never had a problem
we would just go every you know whenever
we would need it and this is the way
that we would do it and they would just
never even think to look because we're
going up and being normal now we'll go
to the to the amusement park
story so
i thought it was it was disneyland and
the thought process was to me i was like
huh
can we get into disneyland
right without without paying is there a
way to get into disneyland i remember
there was a casting director for disney
i had gone out for auditions you know
and the casting director for disney was
a guy named matt casella
yeah so i would call up and say yes i'm
an assistant to matt casella the disney
casting director
we have a bunch of young actors shooting
a movie we want them to have some time
to bond with each other we want them to
come to the park and we want to put we
want to get them some passes to come in
and enjoy the day at the park we really
want them to have some fun
i think it's the name because matt
cassell on there and it would be
obviously they'd have a list of all the
disney employees
my name's not on it i would make up a
name like remote victims or something
they say your name's not on the list sir
and i would say well because i'm a
personal assistant for matt well can we
talk to matt i say matt's traveling he's
out of the country he's on a vacation
this came through to me last minute i'm
not going to be able to get a hold of
him
but i think he's going to be pretty
disappointed if we're not able to get
these guys in to bond well you know who
are the actors well i would name the
most famous young actors of the time
right like the guys that everyone knew
like see thomas howard who's right he's
met dylan yeah they go hold on well then
they'd come back and be like well
clearly if tom cruise and these people
are coming to the park and this guy's
name is a casting director that's listed
as an employee
why would we not let these guys in the
park so i would list all the names and
then mine but i was not well known i
could have been just saying you know
yeah and peter b well you would say
peter billingsley too right no i didn't
use peter b for this oh
although i did go with peter b but we
didn't use his his name although you
probably could i did use peter b's name
other times to get into the places i
would call he wouldn't even come but i
would say mr billings from a christmas
story would love to come in tonight but
we're a little nervous about stuff you
know they set us up with bottle service
whatever but anyway
so i would always say put them i'd say
can you please just put these tickets
under tom cruise's name so that when tom
comes to the will call
i would get it all set up they were
prepared for tom cruise to be the one to
walk up and get the tickets and then
right plus nine right before i hung up i
would always say you know what put it
under vince's name
i don't think tom's going to want to
walk up and see anybody so i did it all
approved and then at the last minute i
would i would change it to the one name
that wasn't well known
but then you get there right
and then when you get to the park
you have to walk up but there's no signs
there's no nothing so i'd have to walk
up with my id to the wheel call by
myself
and give them my id to get these you
know four tickets or however many people
we were taking six tickets
and it would go through and then i would
walk back and you know your hearts
racing to the other the other people
that were coming in and then we and then
we would just take the tickets and
filter in and be in the park it's
brilliant looking back as you get older
you know you go god that's terrible but
at the time as a kid it was sort of that
fun of can i get into a bar when i'm not
old enough can we get access to a place
to go to it was kind of the game of it
so i was always good at getting access
to places or getting off because i think
i was exposed to
to my friend younger who really just did
it as a way to survive
that's amazing and it's also like i'm
sorry even if people are gonna be like
ah that's somewhat off it's fun it's
undeniably a fun story yeah i don't
apologize from that point it was fun and
i did enjoy doing it it is but i'm
saying as you get older you look at a
lot of those things that seemed fun lots
of stuff that we did younger and as you
get older it's like the youth right you
it's it's stuff that at the time was fun
and as you get older it wouldn't be so
much but i we had a blast and a lot of
it for me was too good acting like human
nature and and how you convey stuff to
people and of course the topic it was a
master being around him was really a
master class
life could be a dream sweetheart
i know we have to go soon this is
killing me i can talk to you for hours
did you get rudy in in you got it in
chicago right you were cast no i had
done the improv olympic in chicago
before i left to move to california i
was more interested in pursuing an
acting career than a sketch comedy
career although i love i loved it and i
got rudy in the strangest way i i had
like a lot of at the time i didn't have
an agent you know i had work
sporadically some after-school specials
some guest stars so i had a tape that
had some scenes in it
and i just remember getting a phone call
saying you're going to go do this movie
rudy which never happens they just cast
weird based on my tape
weird it was so weird and then i
obviously went
and did the movie which was a great
experience david anspal who was the
director who was just so great
yeah and everything
like that justin where you got something
off the tape
i uh a mike judge
movie but i had already done a few
things mike said it was the first time
he cast somebody off a tape and it was a
very small part you had a much bigger
role in rudy um and people might be
surprised that that's that that should
be surprising because you're now a very
known person but this is before swingers
this is before this is early 90s mid 90s
um
and did you ever put together what it
was what was on the tape i mean you
would oh my gosh it was just like me
doing like a scene from 21 jump street
china
you know what i mean you know those
teams to get those tapes made where
remember those old headshots
where you'd have to have different looks
right you had like your glasses whether
you were in a book you had on sweat
bands and you were holding half a table
like you were helping a friend move
you'd have a chef's hat on
like take those like the village people
literally i'd have the same look on my
face just wearing different clothes as
if i was really pushing the boundaries
to let them know that yes i could be a
jock but if you're looking if you're
looking for someone who works in a
science lab i'm that guy too because
don't you see i have my my smock on and
i have glasses so i'm an academic
when you met favreau on the set of rudy
was that was it right away that you guys
connected was it like um you just
started making each other laugh was that
something i like john was fun and and he
was in the improv olympics so that was a
common thing but he was funny he liked
to tease and kind of a mean-spirited way
and make fun of you you could you know
do the same so yeah there was
there was a there was a dynamic that was
you know senses of humor for sure
and and with swingers as simple as we
should write something together we
should realize was me saying to him
i'm gonna go write something because
everything we get to audition for is
like whatever like no one's gonna write
something contemporary that's great for
us and then john just went and in two
weeks
it was just something that came out of
them i think basically because of
he was in that position where the world
was new you know i was yeah i had taken
him out to some of these places in that
neighborhood like swing bands and stuff
like that were places i used to go to
and i think he was taking his own
experience and obviously writing and
exaggerating it for comedy so it just
came out of you know it's like they say
everyone has a story or a screenplay in
them
and you just yeah you're just right
didn't you just write and direct
something i did yeah i can't wait to
send it to you with my brother uh we we
loved it but it was it was we love buddy
comedies we love odd couple comedies and
i think that's why i have such a
i mean wedding crashes is great
regardless but i love movies like that
swingers made is one of our faces so we
were really inspired by movies like that
and and uh i just love the the the
simplicity of those dynamics and
and like you said they don't really make
movies like that because they're they
were all about there was so much they
were character based they were
um it wasn't about necessarily funny
lines it was uh about characters who
were evolving and and
in funny situations maybe but i i just i
i feel old you know i know we've been
texting a lot about these old movies and
john hughes but i lately i've been like
god they don't how many times do you say
that they don't make them like that
anymore and i i wonder why you you can
articulate better than anyone
what made somebody like john hughes
so great and and
what made the movies that you were
making so last um
what what do you think it is that's been
lost i mean you touched on it earlier
well john was so special and i had the
good fortune of getting to know him
really well yeah i didn't know that he
lived in lake forest which is the town i
was raised in i moved it to lake forest
when i was about eight um i did not know
him younger those movies were coming out
and so it was
that was the the area that i lived in
but later in life once i had had some
success i reached out to him just as a
fan
and he was so gracious to me
john did so much for people
financially with giving to causes and
giving to people and also with his time
and he never took public attention for
it like when he passed away there was
some pen pal letters that came out a
girl
sent to a magazine i think it was vanity
fair and she sent in these these letters
that she had
as an exchange with john
what she didn't realize was she was one
of very many like john would get engaged
with these kids who wrote and i think
the essence of her
was that she was impressed with his
writing you know think about this when
john was writing those movies
there wasn't a lot of female leads in
films he said he had a hard time with
the studios getting those made because
they would say yeah we can't have a girl
as a lead
because
men make the
the purchase choices the men decide what
to go to
and john said what house do you live in
like there's lots of things my wife
makes the decision on
stuff like that's not even in reality
which i think justin is a good thing for
all of us to realize like even right now
there's certain sayings
that become things that the movie
industry says that these are like facts
and they're not like they'll say you
need to have an ip
so much so that they'll take a board
game and make a movie out of it but just
because someone likes a board game
doesn't mean they're going to see a
movie about you know what i mean right
right right so then we all start to
create and wrangle gosh we have to have
an ip which is totally not true
you know there aren't these rules that
exist like back in the day they used to
say you can't have a a female teenage
league which is like i don't know who
came up with this
but john who was just a great listener
and a great writer wrote these terrific
characters whether it was 16 candles
breakfast club or right pretty in paint
so this the exchange of this letter was
and they're out there they're published
you can
maybe link yeah i want to read that but
but she wrote something in regards of
loving what he did and was inspired and
she said something in the letter how she
had a teacher who was critical of her
writing and john wrote something back
like just beautiful like why would you
worry what someone else thinks do you
like your writing it's fun to write like
if you like it keep going
he has to have exchanges with him like
it's just a simple kind encouragement
right and a rightful yeah like you can't
put all your self value on the opinion
of a so-called expert or in the hands of
someone else you have to you have to
come up with your own set of standards
and you have to live up to what you find
to be valuable vince was that a lesson
you had to learn i mean was that a
lesson that that you learned
yeah i think you learn at a young age
like what matters how you feel about
something versus the approval of others
was always
kind and connected he never lost that
sense of being a child which means your
hopes or looking to feel good somewhere
and he would nurture that or play
ping-pong with anyone that brought that
genuine use of the table
one of the very many surprising things
but that was interesting
when i went to his funeral so many
people came in and got up and spoke
you know just how much that that he
meant to them right yeah
yeah
and there was a young
black man that got up and talked at the
podium who was raised in lake forest and
from his story he did not have a father
figure
that john really took him under his wing
so much that like john took him to all
the blackhawks games with the family
john would take him on vacations to
europe like you know he became part of
the fabric of the family and this this
gentleman talked about how john taught
him so much and included him and made
him feel like a family member and he was
speaking of
you know how
how he had a
family and was a guy that was getting
married and how he had a life and living
it and was just so complimentary
that it came from the lessons that john
taught him by john just loving him
and just kind of showing him how to be a
family member this is again both of
these are one of many many many and yet
if you look at it right
he wasn't self-promoting
that's to go out there and try to sell
what he was doing to be liked he kind of
really did great things in his life
because he had he was a beautiful person
and then his movies were his story like
the movies you know planes trains and
automobiles breakfast club there's
something in john's movies like the
breakfast club which i find better than
all the teenage stuff afterwards and the
oh god yeah yes
john suggests in that movie you start
with these six archetypes there's a jock
there's the nerd
there's the crazy girl there's the
homecoming queen there's the the kid
that's kind of from the wrong side of
the tracks right
and they all feel so different
and they're all like against each other
and what that movie reveals is a truth
that all these kids are hurting
they're way more alike than different
and what made me and all of us younger
at the end of those movies was i
actually felt closer to my cat
classmates
he was revealing that we're probably all
go like it's not easy for the wrestler
emilio estes and the pressure he's under
the homecoming queen has her stuff the
nerd has his stuff and when the movie
ended it wasn't like oh the nerds are
great and all the jocks are bad except
for the pretty girls the pretty girls
are cool and the nerds are cool and
john's movie he was saying everyone's a
human
everybody's hurting no one feels safe
sharing all of their things
that somehow
the guy who seems the most opposite to
you is probably more similar than not if
you had a chance like the breakfast club
to connect you come to realize that
human beings and i think this is as true
today as it always has been there's more
things that are similar that we can
connect to than a zero-sum game where
one group wins and one group loses
well i agree vince that's one of the
reasons i love doing the show too
because i'm constantly seeing that in
people and people that i ha i have
preconceived notions about um
it's like dave bautista this a massive
guy you'd look at that guy and think oh
he
he had it easy he could conquer anybody
and he's
he has some and there's there's pain
that people uh
explore and and and i think that's why
we're all drawn to acting we are we're
all like you said earlier you know we're
part of this this
group of of people who have come
together for a reason and are able to
bond for a reason it's one of the
reasons i like to learn about ourselves
and the world around us you have a
curiosity you're in pursuit of trying to
understand right why yeah yeah why why
do you human beings do things it's like
why are we hurting why am i laughing so
it's like listen you're curious i think
you and me are similar that younger i
was far more of an observer
i could be in settings and not feel
confident but i loved watching people we
were talking on the thread earlier about
planes trains and automobiles oh yeah
which we love that
well
you found interesting
you know the scene we were talking about
it's when it's when john candy's sitting
in his car
and uh and and he's
talking to his wife his dead wife
and it's snowing out and and there's
that
at the them you you had mentioned you
were pointed out how brilliant john
hughes was when it came to music and and
there's just that synthesizer kind of
like
crescendoing in the background it's just
beautiful steve martin opens the door
amazing about him was i would i was
fortunate i'd go to his house until like
seven at night and we'd be up till like
six in the morning just talking like me
and you do right and and investigating
but music wow think about it this was
before the internet so he would go to
record shops and just sift through
albums and if you look at a lot of the
bands and music that he made popular
they weren't hits like he wasn't
spending to put a hit in his movie he
was actually finding music that no one
really knew like a lot of those celtic
fans like simple minds and stuff he was
finding songs
and then
and then you know putting those things
in the movie and i think he was picking
some of those things out even prior to
writing but then those songs became
these great you know hits
but he was he was introducing them to us
he wasn't taking things and selling them
you know which is like he was musically
he knew so much about the origins of of
music and
they never over
and and like old hillbilly music and he
was just a historian he was so radically
bright but a great combination of that
and being really fun to to talk to about
stuff including i bet i bet well that's
uh that's how you that's that's you my
friend i'm thank you
for doing this i this is exactly how i
feel about you i i uh this is i i've
been doing this for a little while and i
i've been thinking about having you know
can't wait to talk to you but um uh i
had always thought we were gonna do it
in per person you know it's it's that's
why i think we had been i've been
putting it off because it was it was
you know this is weird to do it on zoom
yeah i guess
yes but it's i can't wait to see you um
but i love you i adore you you're so so
talented and
so smart and you have such a great you
know um curiosity and you're generous
and fun i'm just so grateful that i've
gotten to know you and have you as a
friend for all these years justin you've
brought a lot of laughter to me and
and i just i just adore you man
i love you so much i i i did i
prematurely ended the show too because i
have a lightning round okay let's do it
is that all right let's do it
um
uh i love you though i that means the
world
you've been just the best um
what is your most commonly used emoji
i don't i probably just a thumbs up i
don't use a lot
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
that changes as i've gotten older
because i don't want to fall and get
hurt i don't play golf i'm not a golfer
but that seems like something where i
could relax a little bit on the course i
i know i want to get into it yeah
uh um if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be your go-to snack food i can't get
enough of these things it would be rice
krispie treats
oh yeah homemade rice krispies treats
are a nice
i'll do the whole tray i do a whole tray
too yeah my wife will make it because
it's a problem
oh yeah the whole tray
i yeah you're i mean it's not as
impressive um
for you to say because you're a bigger
person but yeah i just got off that i
just i did it i'm about to go shoot this
this uh film so i just did like a 10-day
cleanse and lost i was going to say you
look great thank you i had to i had to i
had to i had to get i had to get
quarantine i was eating like it's my job
and now i've i've come back to normal so
i'm not going to have any rice krispie
treats but i would i really enjoy a nice
rice krispie treat
oh yeah what do you put peanut butter in
the rice krispies treat or chocolate
chips or just simple marshmallows and
rice simple simple simple baby yeah
uh what is your this is i i hate asking
people this so i have to amend it a
little your favorite movie or a movie
that you can't wait to introduce your
daughters to i'll just say the first one
off the top of my head knowing it could
change but one flew over the cuckoo's
nest oh god yeah yeah but i think i
related to that movie
i bet you talk about a
you see
i think everyone does the sense of being
caged and and uh i i have a real problem
with bureaucracy and um always had a
problem with authority authoritarian
characters um
yeah i bet but i can see you relating to
it a lot
no it was like i remember being a kid
and liking to joke and laugh and have
fun you were probably similar like i got
along with all different groups i just
like to get i just had fun and i had
different engines right but i the
teachers that the authority didn't like
she really didn't like me because i
would think for myself
and i would question [ __ ] sometimes one
time a kid my school got up you ever
have this he was the kind of kid that
just he was lovely one on one he was a
wrestler but he just didn't like to talk
except to give a speech and he was a
redhead and he gets up to give a speech
and his face is turning red it's like so
much like emotion is there
and the teacher kept making him stand up
there and he like couldn't talk he was
like he was going to have a heart attack
and then i told him to sit down i said
give him i said it's over i said he
didn't give the speech
and the teacher was like i can't sit
down i said yes he can he's sitting down
there's nothing he's gaining from this
this isn't helping anyone and then he
left the classroom and i think he went
and punched a window yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] like there's no like tough love
moment there's nothing this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is putting this [ __ ] kid
through this [ __ ] he's got to live with
us like you know how it is that becomes
his legacy
totally yeah because i think i knew what
it felt like to get the thumbnails on me
you know well also when i was a kid they
were like oh we think he might have too
much energy and you gotta test him to be
you know hyperactive and you know i was
really just curious and and stuff so so
i knew that feeling so i when i saw that
movie i was like well yeah what's he
doing wrong he kind of wants to have fun
yeah yeah things but the nurses like and
then it's like amazing in that movie
when you come to find out that it's
voluntary
that those guys are all
for some of them billy doesn't is
attracted to girls but he has to sit on
it it's somehow bad that he wants to be
intimate with someone and he's using to
take medication and it's a shock when
nicholson's character finds out that
these guys are there by choice
some of yeah and and his reaction it's
almost like he feels betrayed he feels
like who has tricked you into this who
is who has convinced you
that you're uh that you are this way
that that you're bad or i think that's
like the path that we chose as actors in
life it's like you want to say to people
like it's okay to have some fun
you know you have to be perfect at
everything you don't well
everything people are telling you to do
to have a great life like take a minute
what do you like like you come in this
world to be your authentic self follow
your bliss like and maybe have your own
value system
like when we started off to be actors i
never thought i'd make money i never it
would never have mine i just thought
if i could i was like if i could get
into play or get a couple lives on a tv
show and my big thing watch it i was
like
i remember every time i if i got a
commercial or a guest spot i was like
celebrate i've made it you know and you
oh yeah i'm just so excited to work i
never have to totally
of like oh i'm to really this is going
to be a real waterfall
oh no
me either oh [ __ ] i i'm getting a note
from uh i know we've really got to go uh
really quickly if you could have dinner
with three people dead or alive whom
you've never met who would i've never
met
yeah or that you haven't spent
significant time with you'd like to
really like have a meal with them if i
could sit with three people
that i never met
gosh i don't know well let's just go off
the top of my head three people
that i that i never met um
maybe if we're staying in the in the
world of movies and books i would say um
i would say
orwell
uh-huh
i would say
um
kubrick
and um
stephen king
oh did you read the book rage he wrote
under the name richard bachmann
no shorts he wrote a series of books
called the bachmann books because he
wanted to not once he was well known as
stephen king just as a different offer
but he wrote this book which is very
breakfast club is very much darker but
it's called rage it's a terrific
one of my favorite books i read as a kid
huh okay i'm gonna check it out uh if
you if you could live somewhere else
where would it be
if i could live somewhere else where
would it be
um
gosh uh i guess i would say
i've had a little chicken living a lot
of different places you mean a different
state or a different country yeah
anywhere different if you can move your
family somewhere um
maybe
maybe arizona
okay uh
and and if who would you have a favorite
muppet vince of a muppet that you always
really loved
well i really loved all of those muppets
um
as a kid i really liked animal maybe
kermit
uh-huh
yeah
animal
like yeah
i love the animal
yeah um if you could uh would you rather
be called unattractive or unfunny would
i rather be unattractive or unfunny
to have somebody call you unattractive
run funny
well dependent on the person what the
circumstances was
some people would want to find me on
funny others i would prefer if they
found me unattractive so
that's my case situation wrong
um and golden girl which golden girl do
you must identify with dorothy blanche
rose or sophia
i remember the golden girls i don't
remember all of their characters uh b
arthur
yeah i'd say that dorothy yeah uh dog do
you prefer dogs or
cats uh beetles with the rolling stones
okay
that's all we that's all i have for you
i love you so much i i won't be able to
properly gush without it getting weird
so i'm gonna do that in the intro and
the outro with chris you're the best my
friend so fun talking to you dude
congratulations everything i'm super
excited to see your new movie man
i'm going to send it to you i can't wait
and and i can't wait to see you i'll see
you in a couple weeks too long all right
all right love you man
so that well that just happened oh
that's pretty good well that happened
well that happened it's very you got to
go over here i mean it's really strong
chicago but it's i feel like it's
getting stronger i don't know i know but
it's also like there's but he's got it's
there there's there's the beers the
bears he's got a blend though
he's got a blend of
uh there's a slight southern like
there's a twang
sometimes you know it's really it's such
a unique voice and i don't mean just
like the tone he's also got
the words he chooses that he puts
together are so unique you know
i think you're right he is the world's
very best talker mm-hmm he's the world's
best talker he's my favorite person to
hear talk
which is crazy because think about all
the people a lot of people talk
a lot of people talk yeah yeah most
people i know even the way he says
something as simple as um you're uh good
look you look young you know uh the
porcelain
skin like on you
i love what he said um princeton skin on
you and he said homemade rice krispie
treats are a nice time
yeah last time can you do a whole tray
too oh you can do a whole tray too just
his delivery it's like the combination
of the words he chooses is
there's something kind of old-fashioned
about it's almost like he
formal the way he talks
um i i always go back to like i don't
know the scenes and made he does stuff
those outtakes i it just makes me laugh
so hard such a fertile brain yeah you
know he has and
it it's
it's the cure he has so much curiosity
and i i think him and swinger
specifically it's the combination of
he's so handsome so good looking yeah
he's got like matinee looks oh
beautiful looking yeah and
incredibly sharp and funny and fast
uh and that combination of those looks
and that personality i can't imagine it
ever being replicated no i know
like that you know it's i know those
people who look like that are they have
one they might have a certain kind of
charm or like cool factor yeah but they
don't have that quickness where it
really struck me as being like
totally unique not to him but to his
family was when i played i will never
forget this playing
i visited uh his house where he grew up
and
we were playing catchphrase with his
sisters
and victoria and the two of them they're
they're all v names right they're all
v-names yeah
yeah um
and victoria's kind of like she's a
producer on she writes too really funny
writer on f is for family and she kind
of talks like this hey babe
she talks like him but like higher
pitched and she goes after him they the
two of them to get like because her mind
is equally she's quick too you can see
where he came from when you when you
play a board game with them and they
were kind of competitive and like it's
so it was so entertaining what playing
catch phrase
i was really impressed by
him talking about not wanting to hurt
people
kind of his ethos yeah in general i know
we've had this debate before about like
is that type of personality could that
be considered
bullying like the stuff he does
but i think um
i don't think it is because he he has a
real awareness
for not hurting people well he says it i
mean he says you know we're all made up
of these we're all human beings that are
made up of um
you know different pieces and and
different components and
what is mean you know what something and
you know something that somebody might
construe as being mean or offensive
um every
it depends on who's absorbing it who's
watching it so when
you know when my this guy i was talking
who said that the other day about those
movies in the 2000s i don't know what
his experience is i don't know what
triggered him uh
i've never found
a performance of vince's
coming from a place of nastiness or
meanness or at all at all in fact if
anything he's able to he does what very
few people can do like what bill murray
or we're talking about don rickles some
people like that can
um
say
kind of off-color things or potentially
even
insulting things but say it
you know
in a way that has uh that is charming
that is it they say it from a place of
war it is not very similar to don
rickles yeah it's it's like he can bust
your balls but it's
it's loving the way i got to meet don
rickles very briefly and he said some of
the most insulting things to me
about my looks about my told him i would
what are you italian you know and then
he went after italian but he it all
there was a twinkle in his eye that was
so apparent it wasn't even like he was
just he just seemed like a loving person
well i think a really good example of of
what we're talking about with vince is
the story he told about
um
when he was in school and that yeah
nervous i know red-haired kid who looked
like he used to have a heart attack was
was being made to speak and the teacher
was not letting him off the hook and he
stuck up for him in a way that i i've
never done with anybody i mean that's
such an impressive it's impressive to do
to stand up to the teacher yeah and say
ballsy hey you should sit down it's like
he's using his powers for good to me
that's like the exact opposite of a
bully a bully would have yeah laughed at
that kid struggling well and that's why
he correctly i think called me out for
my assessment of trent in swingers i
think trent is as he says a guy who was
trying to lift up his friends he was
you know it's a there's a way to read
that i suppose again it depends on who's
watching it i agree with you i agree
with what he was
that's the thing i everything he was
saying about that character i think was
right
about him being a good friend but i also
think
that character was on the misogynistic
side and it was granted it was 25 years
ago and things are different now but
it's the thing i also think about some
of those scenes the way he he was he was
pretty rude to women in that movie yeah
yeah
his admiration and love for john hughes
uh i didn't know that he had that but it
makes perfect sense that he does because
john hughes was the master at
storytelling yeah and
and just having such a good grasp on
character and hearts heart yeah people
might and that's vince in a nutshell i
think people might not think of him that
way when people think of vincent oh it
kills me whenever i hear
oh vince is in these frat they call it
the frat pack
but i i think you're really like
discounting and discrediting like how
much heart he has in his performances
and how much of that he's writing too
like the scene with um
oh god what a brilliant actor who passed
away sadly um
who plays the priest in wedding crashers
do you remember his name
uh wonderful actor the two of them have
the scene i'm almost positive and i wish
i had asked him about this to to clarify
uh i'm almost positive that whole thing
was improvised wow
where they sit down and uh and he says
come in come in here for the real that's
an example of that that line has become
how many guys have you heard
women have you ever used that line come
in here for the real thing
but that's the kind of thing he used to
come in here for the real thing all the
time and i would hear lines like that
hanging out and
marvel at where that came from and then
i remember seeing wedding crashers and
um and thinking oh i've heard that
that's but he's using
you know if now everyone's heard it yeah
it's really uh he's a special he's a
real genius let's read a letter okay
good
all right
well i like that i like how you took
over from william kratz subject
community and coupons and bones to pick
brother brothers he sent a picture by
the way
oh okay
okay he's a there's a picture with uh
william and his son and he's oh yeah i'm
zooming in he's got a little frog he's
holding a frog assuming it's his son
yeah
nephew or his his um maybe he's in the
big brother program yes
okay we don't want to make assassins
william kratz says
the kid is very cute a little ginger kid
that might be his son uh he's somebody's
son
brothers long and maggie writing to you
from appleton wisconsin
found your show mid covet and has been
an unusually optimistic thing that i
appreciate not normally into the
uplifting content but for sure needed it
oh that's nice that
he finds it uplifting
i listen to your show while i deliver
mail and this year it's been trying with
package and political mail volumes off
the volume off the charts i bet justin
you remind me so much of one of my high
school buddies oh
and the two of you make me reminisce
about the conversations we would have
stoned that's nice
the interviews like when we were like in
high school yeah
uh the interviews could be longer ah but
not at the expense of your brotherly
banter long form no pun intended
conversation is needed in this time of
sound bites and echo chambers
totally agree yeah here here yeah but
that's kind of what we're saying bones
to pick are as follows
i don't know if i'm ready for this uh
number one i was feeling so good about
the show
number one your wisconsin accent is what
we do for upper michigan people okay
we we sound like dan patrick
how does dan pat dan do you know uh i'm
trying to pick dan isn't saying patrick
just sort of milwaukee wisconsin i i'd
picture him just sounding like this like
up next on sportscenter here's um he's
kind of flat and he's very dry i can
picture him i'm trying who's that boy
we've been listening we've been watching
football who's that announcer in
football who every once in a while he's
got like a flat a who's got i guess dan
patrick is a bit of a flat eye uh-huh
all right well i'll remember that when i
do uh wisconsin i'll i'll just i'll say
it's up for michigan
number two justin is right skittles are
eaten by flavor unless in a hurry and
it's grape okay here's oh interesting
let's just
who has to eat skittles in a hurry oh
[ __ ] i gotta you know what i'm doing
uh running out the door justin is right
it's also funny that i'm right
it's a funny thing to say about well i
don't think you're wrong because i don't
think it's a right wrong thing it's just
a preference i know
i think i think he knows that like all
the colors of skittles colors the
rainbow people are all different and
should be celebrated
you know this is william's order he
calls himself billy later on but
william's order is of of worst to best
skittles uh he doesn't say i i worse to
best yes he does say afterwards oh wow
here's his worst to best grape orange
apple lemon and strawberry
weird weird i'm surprised that lemon is
that high huh that grape is that low and
that grape should
and strawberry should be on either end
of the spectrum you know some people
really hate that fake grape flavor i
know people who hate
any sort of grape candy
because it's very artificial see i
always loved it like too there were
times right it tastes almost nothing
like grapes
yeah yeah like like diamond tap remember
how good that was so great children's uh
chewable tylenol oh yeah remember those
the strawberry and the red and the
purple i prefer the liquid diamond tab
oh really i prefer the chewables um you
know what's funny is that now i'm
thinking that skittles kind of like
instructs you how to eat it he's saying
that like that you're meant to eat it
one at a time flavor at a time but they
used the rainbow yeah oh i never thought
about that yeah
okay again uh this is back to william
again love the show thank you and he
says billy k that's how he wants me but
from william kratz he he likes billy k
p.s just wanted to hear you stumble on
the words community in cuba and so
that's why they were in the
god that's really funny that's a
listener yeah wow this has somebody like
coupon you feel like mom i say coupon
though i think when i said it in this
this time because i was self-con i was
self-aware of it enough that's funny
that's something that's fine that's a
good listener
community would you rather from producer
me
billy didn't include one oh okay thanks
miche okay would you rather oh i'm
excited for this one from mich
would you rather live until you are 200
but look like you are 200 the whole time
even though you are healthy or
look like you're 25 all the way until
you die at 65. that is a good question
so you're 200 for your whole life like
even up until you're
and it's
it's hard i've i've never
seen a 200 year old person uh nor is
anybody but
imagining
my face at 200 is
would be awful i mean i would
i would look awful by the way by the way
but i would still 100 pick that because
i also wouldn't want to look like i'm 25
all the time ah that's true but does
that do mesh do you mean
200 from like the time you're
gone through puberty like yeah are you
like or do you look like you're 25
starting from when you're born
that yeah maybe we need you to clap i
would say if it's i would imagine that
it's like once you become an adult you
look 25 or 200 okay and if that's the
case i would
man that's hard because to look 200 you
still get to do all a lot of things in
the world and you're healthy she says so
it's not like you're
slow acting like a 200 year old whatever
you just have a really wrinkly face yeah
um but that would be the only face you
know
so that is that everyone else yeah knows
yeah so everyone thinks you're just like
an old-looking person
there'd be limitations obviously
but um
i would pick that 200 years but then
flip side is all your loved ones have
passed away most of them have been gone
for 100 years you got to keep make new
friends younger friends then you're like
good luck doing that
more i think about this maybe 65
really maybe but then you have to look
25 when you're 55 i wouldn't want
something so weird
that's a tough one miesha that's a good
one i i
i think i'm
i think i was better looking at 35 than
i was at 25. oh
yeah you know i think you were too
because you were you still had baby fat
when you were 25 you had this like kind
of fleshy innocent face
yes yeah but you got a little bit more
chiseled than feet so i wouldn't want to
be stuck at 25. by the way speaking of
faces uh i want you to read that there's
a meme of two high school they're two
back to back high school pictures i know
who they are you do right away saturday
steve buscemi and angelina jolie yeah
one of these people is regarded as one
of the most attractive in the world and
the other as one of the least that's
mean it is mean he's not attracted he's
not known to be one of the least
attractive in the world i think steve
buscemi's really
cool looking i do too um but you know
both everything that steve washington is
really cool looking
you know it might also be because
he's just such a wonderful person we
should have him on the show yes um
he yeah um
but anyway is that the end of the letter
yeah so i would pick
200 yeah why not and it's what you know
so you have a wrinkly face i would look
like what's that dog what's that dog dog
no that has all the wrinkles
yeah
going down
um anyway uh thanks mish and thank you
to billy k
and the
uh just the best and the best vince v
the best ever you may be the greatest of
all time he is the goat
um and uh somebody i am very very
fortunate i feel very grateful to know
and he's been just to both of us been so
supportive and him doing the show is
just another yet another example and as
much as we were waxing poetic about him
i don't even think i mentioned
it was so enjoyable listening
to that conversation oh it was so fun
when it was over i was kind of sad yeah
because i thought oh i could listen to
this for another six hours it was so fun
to listen well that's how it's so fun to
listen to well i'm glad because to get a
taste of that's what it's like you know
hanging out with him that's why i miss
him and
i'm lucky to feel like he didn't know
him
uh friend um so thank you thank you
vince and um
thanks to you
and thanks to you and thanks all you
listening and if you guys want to write
in to the show our email address is life
is short at wondery.com
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life short is hosted by me justin long
it's produced and co-hosted by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan monaco senior producers michelle
me lans audio engineer is sergio
enriquez and the two guys who got their
hands on the executive producer job are
marshall louie and hernan lopez for a
company i like to call wandery thanks
guys we'll see you next week be good and
be safe get your hands on each other
[Music]
i like to be humble i'm old school i
don't like to talk a lot but at the same
time am i
talented tell me how you felt about what
just happened there i don't like the
feeling you're sitting there you're
wondering do i have food on my face am i
eating am i talking too much are they
talking enough am i interested i'm not
really interested should i play like i'm
interested but i'm not that interested
but i think she might be interested but
do i want to be interested but now she's
not interested it's an office and i'm
getting i'm starting to get interested i
bet you do it's america you know what i
mean find out what it is and put that
down on the application for college now
all of a sudden you get a little extra
money on the side uncle sam's not the
wiser for it you take that extra money
you buy a motorcycle or something be a
lady maybe you meet a guy when you're at
school and then you'll get pregnant with
child he works out with the guy doesn't
work out the guy who cares i could play
this game forever oh i couldn't i love
it don't you have yeah it's the kind of
thing where literally i play the game
it's like four hours go by and perhaps
play a little game called just the tip
just for a second just to see how it
feels or i'm challenged you're on my
hair because i think i'm good enough to
figure out how to beat myself his wife
will come home and then she'll find him
with a guy named julio wearing leather
helmets and clubbing each other to
johnny's greatest hits where am i
supposed to kiss her don't have to wait
for the door because then it's awkward
it's like well good night do you do like
the ass out hug we like you hug each
other like this and the ass sticks out
because you're trying not to get too
close you just go right in and kiss him
on the lips so don't kiss him at all
it's very difficult trying to read the
situation just really wondering are we
going to get hopped up enough to make
some bad decisions
you